President Trump is keeping the world
guessing over his plans from North
Korea's dictator and its nuclear arsenal
the president said in an interview he
would be honored to meet dictator Kim
jong-un quote if it would be appropriate
later in the day a White House spokesman
said conditions are not there for a
meeting meanwhile two US strategic
bombers flew a practice mission over
South Korea while the CIA director
visited the country's capital a US
missile defense system is now partially
operational in South Korea China
demanded overnight that it be removed
major garrett is at the White House
where the president will have another
important conversation in just a few
hours major good morning good morning
that's right president Trump will speak
by telephone to Russian President
Vladimir Putin just after noon Eastern
today yesterday the president said he
would be willing to meet face to face
with North Korea's dictator that's
something no sitting US president has
done nobody's safe I mean who safe the
guys got nuclear weapons in several
interviews Monday President Trump
denounced North Korea's nuclear program
and pursuit of ballistic missile
technology of 28,000 troops on the line
and they're right there and so nobody's
safe were probably not safe over here if
he gets the long-range missiles we're
not safe either
North Korea has not carried out a new
nuclear test as some analysts fear even
so dictator Kim Jong Un's government
threatened to bolster its nuclear force
to the maximum with tensions high the
president told Bloomberg News he quote
would absolutely negotiate with the
North Korean leader adding quote I would
be honored to do it he's still a head of
state White House press secretary Sean
Spicer rationalized why talking to Kim a
ruthless leader who starved his own
people and assassinated political rivals
would be an honor there's a diplomatic
pieces but the bottom line is the
president's going to do what he has to
do closer to home the president
discussed another conflict he says could
have been averted the Civil War I mean
had Andrew Jackson been a little bit
later you wouldn't have had the civil
war mr. Trump said in a radio interview
that President Andrew Jackson who was a
slave owner could have negotiated a
solution to decades of division over
slavery and it's economics
he was really angry that he saw what was
happening with regard to the civil war
he said there's no reason for this
Jackson who died 16 years before the
start of the Civil War is seen by mr.
Trump as a populist inspiration
something he discussed with face the
nation's John Dickerson the picture of
Andrew Jackson I put up because they
said his campaign and my campaign tended
to mirror each other if there is a theme
here it's that on many topics whether
it's the complexities of health care the
difficulties of the president or the
underlying and unresolved issues at the
heart of the Civil War what President
Trump either doesn't know or has learned
on the job appear to genuinely surprise
him
Norah all right major Garrett thank you